[Music]
all right so this
is the oneplus 9
how do i describe this phone this this
feels like the phone that oneplus felt
like they had to make you know they're
super into they're very hyped very
expensive flagship phone but they can't
only make a hyped expensive flagship
phone so this video goes hand in hand
with my 9 pro review my last upload so
if you haven't seen that this video is
the is the cherry on top of that sunday
the
20 minute detailed
hasselblad deep dive software oriented
sunday
this one goes in addition to that so if
you haven't watched it already i'll link
it below the like button but this phone
this phone
i think could have been
an awesome deal
but it's it's actually kind of
frustrating how close it gets so if you
can look past all the hype around the
oneplus 9 pro and just look at it as a
phone i actually think they did what
they were trying to do they made a
flagship with the full checklist of
flagship features high-end specs pretty
nice build fast charging and improved
camera and all of that for less than
something like an s21 ultra or any of
the other thousand eleven hundred dollar
phones
fine but this phone oneplus 9
729
and that's pretty good that's very
competitive as far as snapdragon 8
phones go that's about as low as we're
seeing it at launch
and so that's really great that's
competitive but watch how the choices
start to get a little bit weird from
there so the design here the design is
i'm gonna say acceptable but pretty
generic like it's it's a rounded
polycarbonate plastic shell and plastic
rails they're shiny of course so they
look maybe kind of like metal if you're
not paying too much attention but they
aren't metal and honestly if i didn't
tell you how much this phone cost just
by weight and feel in the hand and the
materials i feel like you could easily
mistake this for actually a much cheaper
phone like literally a nord or any other
three four hundred dollar glossy plastic
phone it would have been nice if they
separated themselves in some way from
all the other
glossy fingerprinty plastic phones that
are out there
as much as i hate the glastic term
samsung's s21 which is mostly plastic is
a really good example of this like you
never say it actually feels or looks
super cheap in the hand you hold it it's
decent maybe you'd be more into like a
faux leather or something like from the
xiaomi mi 11 but also maybe i'm
overreacting maybe you're just gonna put
it in a case anyway in which case ignore
that that's just my two cents now with
the specs they still do the oneplus
thing here it's the snapdragon triple
eight eight or 12 gigs of ram 128 or 256
gigs of storage and a 4 500 milliamp
hour battery for those of you who have
already seen the 9 pro review you may
recognize that as the exact same set of
specs
as the 9 pro which is of course more
expensive so that's where we expect
oneplus to be competitive lower prices
still keeping high end specs
but there are a couple small cuts so
this cheaper version does not have
millimeter wave 5g support
not a huge deal right now this phone
still has the ridiculously fast 65 watt
warp charging setup that's been so
convenient and it still has wireless
charging but just at a standard 15 watts
nothing too crazy fine for topping up
overnight and makes perfect sense if you
weren't gonna buy some
seventy dollar specialized charger
anyway and then for water resistance
where sometimes you see cut
the t-mobile version does say it's ip68
certified
maybe just t-mobile decided to pay for
that but since they're all built
the same i think we can safely assume
they're all somewhat dust and water
resistant and this phone is just really
enjoyable to use mainly because of that
display where i think they nailed it for
this price it's nearly the same size as
the pro 6.55 inches and it's great it's
flat at the edges instead of curved over
but the bezels are still thin and the
display goes right up to the edges is
great for watching videos with this
speaker setup too that's just as loud as
the nine pro the screen doesn't get
quite as bright as the brightest
flagships but it's still manageable and
it's 1080p 120 hertz
so this is a nice screen and you'll
notice it's just 120 hertz it's not
smart 120 hertz since it's not an ltpo
panel
they've had slightly weird panels in the
past where sometimes you can see off
axis yellowing maybe rainbowing but i'm
not seeing nearly as much of that here
so there's there's no distractions when
just watching videos or gaming or
whatever you're doing
i'm going to call out this odd
fingerprint reader placement every time
i see it though
i still think it's weird that it's so
low on this phone but
other than that using this phone
flipping through oxygen os with all its
animations and multitasking has been
super fast thanks to the screen
and then there's a camera layout on the
back so you can see it's one less camera
than the nine pro so this has a
different sensor but the same size
primary 48 megapixel chip in there it
has the exact same ultrawide which is
one of the best in any phone
and then it drops the telephoto but
keeps the two megapixel black and white
camera
why but like i said using this phone
overall
is still great like this is what oneplus
has gotten so good at there's not a
single thing missing from this software
that's in the nine pro like they've been
very willing to tweak oxygen os over the
years make it smoother add features
most people who aren't coming straight
from a more expensive phone
will find this perfectly fine it handles
multitasking everyday use exactly the
same as its 969 dollar brother there's
no extra stutters no earlier drops in
the ram it even had slightly better
battery life in our testing otherwise
same deal but of course it's my job to
point out the things that aren't quite
the same in this phone so you're not
surprised when you get them
so
just so you know the haptics in this
phone
aren't quite as good they're not as
strong they're pretty weak honestly um
and they're not quite as tight now they
still lean into it in the software so
they emphasize the haptics a lot when
you drag brightness and volume and a lot
of other ui elements in the stock apps
like in the clock here it still feels
like it's trying to emulate that
high-end haptics but it's not as great
the alert slider on this phone is also
much looser than it was on my pro and
you know what maybe it's just this exact
phone i got but it's so loose that it's
particularly easy to switch it to ring
as you pull the phone out of your pocket
and then it's not quite the same camera
setup as the pro like i said it's the
same size main sensor but it's a
different 48 megapixel sony sensor for
the main camera it still gets the
hasselblad branding though and it still
looks slightly more natural like this
more muted color profile than before so
it looks pretty much the same in good
lighting and almost has this neutral
version of a contrasty pixel-like look
but you can't zoom in nearly as far of
course without it starting to get soft
there is a 2x button here in the
viewfinder but that's just a digital
punch in and that's about as far as i'd
go if i want a good quality photo
the ultra wide is amazing like i said
honestly it's the best part of this
particular camera system this year
but then the shutter lag that i talked
about from the oneplus 9 pro it's still
here there's still this overall weirdly
slow camera performance
and i'm really hoping that that's
something that's fixable through a
software update
and then let's let's just talk about the
two megapixel monochrome camera for
those who are wondering why i said i was
just going to ignore it in the nine pro
review
the best case for this extra piece of
hardware they've thrown in here
according to oneplus is it helps add
detail to your black and white photos
which
number one it's two megapixels
how much detail could it possibly be
adding to the 48 megapixel sensors
black and white photos
but also number two
just for black and white photos
like if i want to take a good black and
white photo i don't know about you but i
just take a regular photo and then later
i just make it black and white i just i
just turn the colors down saturation off
so this is
it's it's basically a useless extra
piece of hardware to me look this extra
sensor is a waste of money a small
amount of money but it's a waste of
money and you should have spent that
money on something else
changed my mind but long story short
oneplus 9
is a pretty good phone and it's one that
i'll be recommending to certain people
but not all you know some phones are
just so good overall that you can sort
of blanket recommend them to a bunch of
people this isn't quite that phone but
for people who value the oneplus
software experience like the the clean
near stock type of look the fast and
smooth experience
the fast charging that they offer all of
that
this phone is actually i think sneaky
good value like i obviously don't love
the design as i said maybe put in a case
fine but if you weren't going to buy
that extra 70
turbo wireless fast charger
and if you're cool with 1080p flat and
no telephoto
this using the phone experience this
software experience
is exactly the same to the spec to the
speed to the performance it's exactly
the same
as the phone that costs 240 dollars more
whether you believe it deserves to cost
that or not
that's what makes this actually a pretty
good deal now if you compare it to
something like the galaxy s21 which
launched at a little higher over price
but now is roughly 700 bucks this is
probably what oneplus was looking for
this is probably about the comparison
they were aiming at and it's
kind of a toss-up like for build quality
i would give the edge even though
they're both plastic i would give the
edge to samsung because the camera and
the rails are metal and they've got a
nicer finish then they're both 120 hertz
flat 1080p displays
but i would again give the edge to
samsung just a little bit for extra
brightness then they've got the same ram
same storage same snapdragon triple
eight but i give the edge to one plus
for the bigger battery and the faster 65
watt wire charging i think this is a
better battery setup and then they're
both triple camera systems technically
but i'm giving the edge to samsung
because there's a real zoom in there and
they didn't waste a sensor so
and then it's just software how much do
you prefer what samsung's doing with
theirs versus what oxygen os is doing on
oneplus phones
i personally would prefer oxygen os and
i think i would lean towards this phone
over this one but it's going to be about
your priority are you about that battery
are you about that software
are you about that camera it's all about
you so there you have it it's the
oneplus
9.
it's a good phone if you know what
you're getting yourself into no doubt
cast in a little bit of a shadow by the
hype of the oneplus 9 pro but
this is worth looking at
there you have it thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace